these drugs in an illegal environment or
more accessible to our kids because we
leave complete control regulation and
standards up to the criminals hi I'm Ted
baliker with reason TV and today I'll be
speaking with Neil Franklin Franklin is
executive director of leap Law
Enforcement Against Prohibition what
would happen if we legalized or
liberalized or decriminalize drugs in
the US market you know people talk about
or what about the unintended
consequences of heading down that road
of legalization have you looked at the
consequences we're dealing with now you
know you're talking about what could
possibly happen keep trying to compare
that to what is already happening as far
as the violence cartels in over 230
cities right now do growing marijuana in
our national parks with armed guards in
the trees with ak-47s are you kidding me
it seems like okay if you let's say
you're in favor of drug prohibition
because you don't like drugs for a
variety of reasons I get that but it
seems like even if you don't like drugs
you really really don't like murder rape
robbery and so forth and if you look at
the clearance rates for you know that
the FBI keeps raped 40 percent clearance
auto theft 12% robbery 27 percent 2008
figures basically this means most of the
rapists for instance are getting away
with it what would happen if we stop
focusing on policing drug crimes and
focused like a laser on things like rape
and robbery I'm so glad you asked me
that question the clearance rate of
homicide nationally in 1963 was 91
percent 9 out of 10 homicides we solved
today let's try 63 percent that's a huge
drop and it's obvious that we are focus
focus on our resources from the law
enforcement perspective upon prohibition
the average cop on the street how much
of his time is spent protecting the good
people from the bad people versus
policing Victor
less crime the average patrol officer on
the street and in the neighborhood says
911 and what I mean by that is they're
moving from 9-1-1 call to 911 call many
times they're backed up you know three
five ten deep so they clear one then I'm
moving to the next cleared and clear and
they're moving to the next it's just a
constant journey from one call to the
next the overwhelming majority of those
calls have to deal with I've got drug
dealers on the corner where it's
something related to the illegal drug
market yeah we had the shootings you
know but we wouldn't have those
shootings if we didn't have the drug
market what if it were different what if
drugs were legalized how would the cops
that you worked with how would their
day-to-day be different we have drug
units that have a few hundred people and
for instance and and agency that has say
about three thousand men and women their
drug unit is probably gonna have about
10% of that three hundred and some-odd
members into that unit you could take
the majority of those folks put them
back out into the districts fully staff
your precincts in your districts and
with the absence of running 911 one call
to 911 one call when you do get a call
of domestic violence well you do get a
call for a missing child you can then do
the work that's supposed to be done
there was great hope when President
Obama was elected that we would have
more sensible drug policy how has
President Obama done so far below
average
I give him a D and the reason I give him
a D is because he came out and said the
war on drugs is over we're gonna focus
on treatment and education but the money
doesn't reflect that two-thirds of the
money is still in law enforcement and
only a third for the Office of National
Drug Control Policy for their budget is
in treatment and education in that
suspect for obvious reasons people are
especially worried about how drug policy
affects kids you hear commentators like
Bill O'Reilly for instance is very very
much against legalizing drugs because
he's worried that
people will take drugs and then abused
kids more often and I heard him talk
about statistics related to child abuse
and those parents who are on a substance
at the time from my front-line
experience responding to those calls
where children are abused responding to
those calls of domestic violence the
drug overwhelmingly being used as
alcohol I can't recall ever responding
to a call or being involved in an
investigation of child neglect or child
abuse which involved marijuana as the
only drug being used if marijuana was
present alcohol was surely there these
drugs in an illegal environment or more
accessible to our kids because we leave
complete control regulation and
standards up to the criminals they
control the entire market and they
control who those drugs are distributed
to and they don't ask for ID they don't
want to know how old you are they just
want to see your money so drugs are more
accessible to our kids in this
environment then if we were to control
them through regulation and and
standards I mean it's a no-brainer and
it seems like the Bill O'Reilly of the
world may have a blind spot a pretty big
one in this case in terms of they they
overlook how the drug war can actually
put kids at risk in Baltimore City
here's an example we have a 60% dropout
rate for young black males and they drop
out for two reasons mostly number one
they're enticed to go into the illegal
drug world because they see the The
Bling and all the glitter and and and
and all that excitement number two
they're recruited recruited quite
heavily to leave high school to leave
middle school and come work for the drug
dealers on a corner and isn't another
one that the gangs will actively recruit
them because they know if they get
caught their sentences will be lighter
than an adult oh of course
I mean it's these kids are very smart
the the adults in these gangs and in the
business
they they have kids hold the drugs sell
the drugs do most of the activity with
the drugs because as you said when they
are arrested they get lighter sentences
they get take it treat it differently
and rightly so that's how our system is
set up to give juveniles as many chances
as possible as relates to the criminal
justice world a lot of people say well
you can't legalized or decriminalized
drugs we'd have chaos they've done
pretty much that in Portugal for about
the past ten years can you talk about
what's happened there they've seen a
significant double-digit drop for
school-aged children use of drugs for
illegal drugs for school-aged children
they've seen a good rise in treatment
because now the addicts don't feel they
had the stigma about them so they feel
free to be able to come out seek and
obtain treatment
additionally they now have the money to
fund the treatment because they're not
spending thousands of dollars housing
addicts in prison so they can take a
small portion of that money and provide
good treatment new cases of AIDS have
dropped by double digits success after
success after success innate and they
haven't even ended prohibition it's
still illegal for the drug dealer to
sell so they had that violence
associated with the illegal drug market
however just to decriminalize they have
these successes that unmounted